[Music]
again you don't do the dirty work I'm a
soccer player this is a roaming gang of
a fluent soccer players
okay whoa and what it's so in the very
beginning yeah in stages number one
let's keep our critical distance we
don't want to get into the zone yet
here's where you want to keep the
distance directly and I notice in the
past you have a very duck like sloppy
style like this
it's okay we've made fun of in the past
but in this situation it's gonna help
you they're left really hard third grade
bully is up there third so okay we're
gonna use your duck slap that you like I
don't call him duck slaps but whatever
distance here your lateral movement
right and then just keep him at bay keep
moving and keep him at bay
keep the zone between you don't let him
in okay
[Applause]
okay that was good he's you're
surrounded I used my surroundings I used
the talkshow test
because when I am attacked it will be in
the studio okay okay so now the next
level we've done you did you've done
your duck slaps you could even add and
kicks to the legs if you want to back
them up right once he goes in for a big
kill then that's when you move in and
isolate the weapon away from his other
hand right so if you can come in after
the fact or you can beat them to the
punch and come in this way and I flew at
the weapon right so once the weapon is
isolated now you have a chance now you
can borrow going to do a sweep right and
then he's dead like very cool so let's
try the whole thing oh that okay with
the Ducks flapped and then when he goes
in for the big strike isolate that
weapon highlight the weapon okay go
[Applause]
that looks gross
okay we got one minute left okay so
let's tie together reveal the curtains
please okay a public restroom why are we
we're gonna use all my techniques why
are we doing this in a bathroom it's the
most dangerous place to be in especially
the evening because there are no
security cameras there are no witnesses
the walls are thick there's only one
entrance one X that someone can see you
come in and you usually caught with your
pants down you're being serious here
bathroom very dangerous okay suppose WI
didn't you sit down we're gonna put you
in the most dangerous situation here
okay I'm is a magazine to read you think
it's just a magazine but if you roll it
up tightly right it really what'd you do
that for just to show you the power can
you tell me I'll understand
it strong yeah okay so you're gonna have
to figure that out use this as an
extension if we had to do your sloppy
duct techniques okay
[Applause]